- I don't really think
I've ever really talked
to my Lyft driver about problems.
I remember once my Lyft
driver sang with me.
That was special.
(upbeat music)
- Whenever I (speaks off
mic) an Uber a lift for work
I'd walk in, say, "Hi!",
and like my phone, right away.
- I think sometimes I
talk to my Lyft driver
when I'm drunk, and we
have great conversations.
- Maintaining a kind of healthy lifestyle
while really busy at work
is what I'm goin' through right now.
- I think I just need like a hobby
that I'm not trying to
make into like work.
- I'm really curious and more delve deeper
into see if maybe there's something
that I'm not knowing about myself.
- I think it's just
weird talking to someone
about my feelings.
I talk to myself sometimes.
Let's see how this goes.
- My name is Cheri Smith,
and I've been driving
for Lyft, three and a half years.
I've had people talk
about relationship issues,
about what he's done, and they just start
talking about it.
I'm not gonna like give my opinion.
I just keep asking questions.
Once it hits the
airwaves, it becomes real.
- I'm from New Jersey, originally.
- Okay.
- I moved out here for school.
- So what'd you study?
- It was business with a marketing focus.
- Okay.
- And then I did a job in that for like,
what like three months,
and then I realized
quickly that I hated it,
and I needed to do something creative.
So it started working, turns out --
- I try to encourage them
to follow their passion.
Are you doing this because somebody
said you had to do this
or are you doing it because
it's what you really want to do?
- Right now, it's kind of like
my job is kind of everything,
just because it's
important to me to do well,
and like I'm in, like
it's pretty competitive.
- Take time for a personal life okay.
- I try to.
- 'Cause you're young.
- I feel like the years are
kind of like fleeting away.
(laughter)
- No, they're not.
- Yeah.
- The last few jobs I had,
I'd approach every single job opportunity,
afraid that I wasn't good enough
or I'd like screw up the job,
and coming here and
being able to do videos
and make things,
- Right.
it just felt like, fuck yeah,
I'm doing something right, you know.
There's just something
about venting your life
to a stranger when you know
that there are gonna be
no repercussions of it.
It's just nice.
- So what's your ultimate goal?
- In life?
- In life, yes.
- So deep.
I get in these conversations
with my passengers.
I like to feel 'em out and
see where they're goin'
in life, what their goals are.
- Longtime goal, I really
wanna own restaurants,
and also, like I'm gay, so
and I really love like film
and TV shows as well,
so if I could ever like
produce TV shows and movies
that have like a food
and queer focus, that'll be like awesome.
That'd be like the dream life.
- Sound like you have some good plans.
- Been told it's like I
have plans A through Z.
(laughter)
And hopefully, somewhere
in there they work out.
(laughter)
- Well there's this saying,
if you wanna make God laugh,
tell him your plans.
(laughter)
They like the fact that
they can talk to strangers,
and they can be themselves.
- Definitely felt a
little bit more relaxed
after my vent session with Cheri.
It was like in the middle of the workday,
so just to be able to take that break
and then come back to
work was a nice refresher.
- Throughout the day,
especially when you're working
so much, you're kind of
like in your own world,
and she was really open
to talking about anything.
- And it really depends
on what kind of energy
you're putting out there.
If I'm like energetic about it,
then, yes, they will
open up, and I like that.
I think they like it too.
That's why I'm a
five-star driver (laughs)!
(jazz music)